and birthday chicken it turns out was in  his family they invented like a birthday  Santa the birthday chicken sort of this  mythical  mythical birthday he'd get gifts from  his friends and family but then he get  one extra gift from the birthday chicken  he gets a little bit older  goes through the reveal that we all went  through granted his was a little  different than ours  there was an addition it was like  there's no tooth fairy there's no Santa  there's no birthday chicken he's like  I'm gonna need a minute  Santa I saw coming but birthday chicken  who is eating all the feed we put in the  living room dad  first semester freshman year at College  in his dorm it's his roommate's birthday  because what I failed to tell you is  what they failed to tell him  that they were the only people that did  it  so he's just handing this seeming  stranger a gift with a card and this  dude just opens it and he's like love  birthday chicken and that's you